Klose gates 6 of our northern cities had  fallen in a coordinated attack their  leader fights alongside of which  crush these murderers your majesty every  family must contribute one man to fight  your war hero you've already made many  great sacrifices  my father cannot fight so I will take  his place  the northern invaders will kill her if I  expose her power all people will kill  her when we take the Imperial City I  will take revenge for my father what is  your name soldier  hygiene commander so no quarrels you  will now take the oath of the warrior  [Music]  release  [Music]  pretending to be something you're not  yet here I stand proof that there is a  place for people like us  a girl threatens our plans  a warrior  [Music]   [Applause] [Music]